okay so we're recording oh really
exciting how's my hair look I can't see
your face yeah that's a shame
I'm sorry stop it run Podcast okay so uh
how was scream for considering it just
or should I call it scruff forum I
really don't like oh that's like not the
official title but it's on like every ad
so people feel obligated to put that as
the official title that's really not the
official title I mean where they replace
the hey with yes Chris that is what I'm
referring to
yeah actually I literally went to IMDB
to see what the official title was so I
could put it in my review because I
didn't know what to put yeah but it's
screaming for ya is I just like sings
perform but that sounds like a body part
as we'd have child in the forum but to
answer your question I thought it was
pretty good I have not seen the other
three recently enough to like rank them
to my liking I like the other two more
and the second one is probably still my
favorite I don't know like I do like the
third one and I like this one I don't
know how it ranked those two I thought
they were pretty similar in a sense of
faults on how they really don't have the
kind of self-awareness that I think the
first who had but it was it was good I
like how there's a lot of characters so
that you know there's lots of you know
play within yourself on who's the killer
is and the twist is really cool yeah but
not all that worked for me I thought
very stupid near the end some of the
writing was pretty bad so the acting was
pretty bad
but overall it was pretty good just I
wait I think the first two are just a
whole lot better and I haven't seen one
two and three and four so long but I
mean I did see all of them I have seen
about before but I think it's my
favorite sequel I don't know I mean I
don't know if I like it wasn't to it
like I said I hadn't seen forever look I
recently watched like the first 15
minutes of to because it was a YouTube
video and I think I like scream for more
I'm not I mean it's like I don't know I
just really enjoyed it and like um I'm
not I don't to give any spoilers but I
was like that killer blew my mind yeah
it's pretty cool I just think it kind of
they went too far with it eventually
like the last ten minutes are just
stupid dude they're so stupid you don't
think it grew overblown at all no I
loved it well that's like one of the
best lines of the year so far
oh yeah I know you're referring to don't
yet for the original yeah there's a tad
bit tongue-in-cheek but um I uh the the
screen movies are known for well
bouncing humor and horror
correct correct like I assume you agree
and being and being able to self parody
the genre that they're in yeah but I
think this one had the same problems the
third one had on where those two things
just don't bounce very well if there are
many moments I thought like maybe the
problems are two different are different
in the two films and the third one I
just thought the humor was too over the
top and this one I just thought some of
the humor was out of place like they're
actually trying to earn laughs like
while people are dying like the series
didn't like wasn't like that it was
funny in the sense of how like they're
making fun of horror movie cliches like
not how like they're making fun of
people dying like they kind of did in
this film I did laugh when the one
character died I don't want to give it
one of the cops I laughed
that's one of the moments Rome like
there doesn't really humor there but
that would work better than some of the
other ones are referring to happened was
funny like he was just like hey and then
he just kind of stabbed in the like in
the forehead I was like can that even
happen and then he starts swinging
around and he's like ever so I was like
what look I enjoyed the I just I'd like
a good scary movie I I don't have always
liked the good scary movie ever since I
was young and there was a whole bunch of
people at the midnight premiere and it
was just a good atmosphere and it was
like perfect release day time to because
this drunk was like the first week
around where I live anyway where it's
been warm so I was like I'm feeling the
summer vibes and stuff it was pretty
cool that's funny is it like a like
snowed slathering like all day here but
anyways no it's been warm all day that's
funny a friend of mine was saying it's
like incredibly windy where she is
that's right oh it was crazy wind here
but it makes with like snow rain ah what
the heck like Canada through Nebraska
must be in some horrible front in Ohio I
was just like yay i'm so hyoe so cool
because that's all we know how to stay
so kind of somewhat relevant to scream
for the the trailer you know of course
shown ahead of time to the Rise of the
Planet of the Apes had me laughing so
hard I hadn't seen the trailer yet
because I think that rise of the apes or
something I thought that's what it was
called my Entertainment Weekly magazine
of all the upcoming moves this year had
it listed as rise of the Apes I don't
know if they changed it or if they're in
Assam they probably meaning it they
probably got like the letter from the
and Entertainment Weekly editors like
it's not called rise the planet yes
that's so that's a mistake where we're
putting rise at the ACE know that
trailer I don't know it's like very
underwhelming well it's not just
underwhelming of this is how stupid it
is this yeah like it doesn't understand
like it doesn't seem to have anything to
do with the fan of the Apes yeah well
yeah that's what I'm saying like I'm
telling myself that there's more to the
story or if it's really they inject
something into these gorillas makes them
smarter to the point where it's a bunch
of gorillas attacking Manhattan it could
be fun but like what's like all these
apes just like start this like in an
army just like start breaking out of
this building I just like sort of
cracking up cuz they're calling it I ate
I don't know if you saw the trailer for
abducted oh my god um it's the Bourne
Identity with Taylor Lautner if any was
gonna be stretch arms me too like when
it started off I thought it was the
trailer for Stretch Armstrong and then
they start talking about all this light
missing identity crap and I'm like I
don't think this is Stretch Armstrong
and then houses start blowing up and you
know come to think of it hasn't the only
been in like one movie since Twilight
the Valentine's Day movie I mean has he
will this be his thing where he could be
like hey let's see if I could do
anything besides have pecs yeah but this
is Valentine's Day all wasn't it all he
did in between the Twilight movies I'm
looking this filmography right now he
was like basically his Twilight
character in Valentine's Day just there
to be that's my life guy yeah
in this movies like trying to milk him
as an action star and it just looks like
a really overblown action movie right um
sure girls ago
yeah it's from the director of too fast
to theories and four brothers so this is
going to be really violated a lot of
explosions what about Taylor Lautner's
those would be great I'm sure I'm
currently I just started watching before
right as you texted me for this I just
started watching the number 23 with Jim
Carrey movie makes no sad so far is kind
of dumb like every oh oh you think you
think it's dumb in the beginning the guy
want to find out when one like the plot
starts but every time I that we do like
a Skype call I'm always about to watch
some retarded movie like last time it
was dead silence you're like hey what do
you want dead silent why cuz it was
directed by James Wan and he just made
insidious and I liked it I remember I
was like is that the evil puppet movie
yep but this one excuse me this one like
it just starts out and it's just it
seems so weird like Virginia Madsen is
just standing there in front of her book
shop waiting for Jim Carrey to pick her
up or her cake shop what is it a book
it's a book shop family bad gonna block
that movie out of my memory because all
people and all women in movies who are
middle-aged for some reason own book
shops anyway she's just standing there
and sees this red book and she's like
I'm going to buy this beat-up obsessed
thriller about the number 23 for my
husband for his birthday so he can
become obsessed with it I mean like what
a weird birthday gift
his son gives him a little cup that says
greatest father ever or whatever that
may support says she's like here honey
here's a book about the obsession of the
number 23 you're a dog catcher right
you'll like it just a stupid way to get
the book in his hands it's dumb and then
he there's like some weird subplot where
he follows a bulldog to a graveyard that
then the bull
like leaves him back to his flight yeah
as she get don't don't say anything I
don't know anything but as as she gives
him the book the Bulldog is watching
it's like with this stupid
don't tell me to not say anything's I
don't think I can have anything for this
because the movie makes no sense at all
okay yeah but I really frankly don't
remember much from it as I had a
retarded I was laughing my butt off like
the Bulldog is watching anyway I can't
wait to see what happens
yeah the movie has deep bestiality other
toes that's gonna be a new Jim Carrey
additive telling me no I'm just gonna be
ready for the twist ending well what do
you think mr. Popper's Penguins is about
boobie could be awful it could be okay I
think it's gonna be awful unfortunately
I don't know what your brother is doing
we a it's based on a love children's
book so it's like know what that means
it's like yeah it's like he went crazy
after he realized he's wasn't getting an
Oscar and decided to make all these
random movies
well don't act like he's had a flawless
filmography up until mr. Popper's
Penguins like it seems like the kind of
movie he'd be in I guess that's true but
I mean it seems like the past right up
until I guess Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind he was doing really well I
mean he had liar liar vs almighty
eternal sunshine Truman Show and now he
has the number 23 and then mr. Popper's
Penguins and it is I don't know
and he hasn't actually been in a movie
since yes man I mean he's been doing
voice acting and son well using the
movie last year what the greater one
right that's right and supposedly that's
his best performance ever
and he's supposedly really really good
at it yet some Oscar buzz um you know
just like he had Oscar buzz for
been shown eternal sunshine and the
majestic and man on the moon yeah yeah
yeah always gets Oscar buzz he probably
just here isn't he's like yep not
happening
not this time it will happen eventually
maybe I don't know it'd make me feel
better if he was at least nominated like
there's those actors that have been snub
so many times there's like oh and then
use know for sure that this is the time
that they're gonna win because they've
been dominated so many times you can't
say that about
I could see exactly what he would do if
he got if he wanted an Oscar he just
runs up to the podium and like
purposefully slips and falls on the
ground and does some slapstick thing and
then just taste it and goes like finally
and gets into some speech but that was
so funny if you like I want to I want to
see that it'd be so fun if you put his
butt up to the mic comes like my girl
for this award you know how an Ace
Ventura he talks out of his butt I'm
gonna seen it bro you should reappoint
yourself well I don't think I've ever
even seen all the first one I just saw
the second one the second one is my
favorite single is pretty funny yeah
sure haha
so anyway I'm kind of in like a scary
movie I don't want to call it a rut
because I'm having fun with it but I
keep what I do but yeah I'm in a rut
where I can't watch anything unless it's
scary cuz I have a giant list of movies
that we'll watch but I can't get to any
of them because I don't want to watch
anything other than a scary movie
currently I just keep watching scary
ones over and over again
I've watched descent 1 & 2 Jeepers
Creepers 2 which was dumb although it
was directed well it just has incredible
and like blatant gay undertones it's
insane and so I looked up some things
and the director is gay and him he's
been convicted of child molestation in
the past so I'm like well that explains
everything look who you supporting he's
a good director
I mean
he's a good job with like pacing and and
and shot the shots are nice but oh yeah
I bet he does yeah yeah so okay Chris